Hi and welcome to the Neil Ashton podcast.
In each episode,
we explained some of the fascinating ways that science and engineering
are changing the world around us.
We talk to leading engineers from elite level sports like cycling and Formula One
to some of the world's top academics.
To understand how fluid dynamics, machine learning and supercomputing
are bringing in a new era of discovery.
We also hear some of their life stories, their career advice
and lessons they've learned on the way that I hope will be helpful to you too.
So sit back and enjoy this episode.
Hi, and welcome back to the Neil Ashton podcast.
Today's episode is really setting the scene for
what are gonna be a couple of really interesting
interviews and discussions
with some
world leading experts on machine learning.
What the next month's episodes are really gonna be focusing on
is this topic of AI for science or how artificial intelligence,
how machine learning
can be used to solve scientific problems
in addition to the way that machine learning is now increasingly being used, uh,
for generative AI for these
large language models that you can go in
and you can ask questions. You can generate images.
Increasingly, you can generate short clips.
How
or is it possible for some of those to also solve some of the scientific problems like
computational fluid dynamics, weather modelling, material design,
drug discovery, et cetera,
And I just wanted to set the scene. Really?
Today is going to be a bit of a shorter episode, and I wanted to maybe,
um,
discuss some of the fundamentals in terms of why this is
becoming interesting.
And I'm gonna talk through the lens of Of of CFD of computational fluid dynamics,
um such that hopefully the next few episodes when you
listen to them with some of these world leading experts,
uh,
you'll get a little bit of another context because
we may dive in straight away in those conversations.
So I thought this one might be useful to
to really explain some of the high level concepts. So
the way I would say it is this.
So let's let's look at, uh, computational fluid dynamics. Let's look at
what the previous you know, nine episodes have essentially been about, which is
OK. I want to design a car or a plane or a wind turbine or a jet engine.
And, uh, I could do it physically,
as in, you know, I could
build it, fly it and test it, but most of the time that's too expensive.
So so people don't do it. That's that's really left, right? You know, to the end.
It's not really a development thing. Sorry.
I think I've got a bit of a cold or something. So my voice is going a bit,
Um,
what is increasingly used more are either
wind tunnel tests.
So some sort of artificial environment that mimics the real world.
But let's say in a very large warehouse where you blow air over like an object or you
do some sort of lab test where you maybe have like a jet engine in S in,
in inside a building which is detached from
a plane and you do some experimental tests.
Um,
but even those are are are arguably still quite slow. And,
um, limit the number of designs you can explore, and hence why?
Simulation is so, uh, widely done now. And hence why?
Computational fluid dynamics is this
important area that is continues to grow in terms of its applicability.
And that's why I constantly talk about CFD because it really is used
in so many of the things that that you're used to doing.
But
if you're doing uh, CFD
and this applies also to, let's say,
drug discovery or weather modelling or materials design.
Typically you're solving some, you know,
partial differential equations using some numerical methods
that essentially have typically,
uh,
a quasi linear relationship between the accuracy
of your simulation
and the amount of time it takes to run
it.
I in general and different methods have different order, uh,
of of of computational cost versus accuracy.
But
you know, in general, let's say, for the simulation of a car,
um,
the to make it more accurate.
I need to reduce the error in these numerical schemes by having
um,
less dissipation smaller digitalization to these sort of
mesh points that you have more of them
to be able to capture more of what's really going on.
And as you add more of that fidelity
in space and time,
because most of the time these turbulent structures have a very small you know,
time scale, and particularly true if we start getting into Multiphase and,
uh,
and combustion and things like that the time
it takes you the number of iterations you
need to run and the amount of memory and compute goes up and up and up.
So, um, that's why high-performance computing is such an important discussion.
It's why I kind of link them together. Fluid dynamics HPC
because they are inherently linked.
But the third topic
that I mentioned, I think, in the intro to every podcast
is machine learning.
And that's why I wanted these next few episodes to really dive in and help
to be honest Me, I learn every time I speak to somebody, uh,
but also yourselves to to get this sense of why
I think machine learning has a strong potential in this area
of, uh, Formula One and cycling and engineering and fluid dynamics.
So
what I said before was, in general,
all these simulations are getting more and more accurate,
but they're also requiring more and more compute
Now.
Interestingly,
machine learning has
developed over the past decade,
I would argue,
but certainly has ramped up in the past
23 years,
to the point that actually,
and I'm gonna speak it at a high level because these next um,
interviews are gonna be the chance where we can go in a little bit deeper.
So this this is like, I guess, the
sort of 101 class
they developed to the point that, in theory,
machine learning is all essentially about inputs and outputs, isn't it?
You know, essentially, you've got some input, some data
that you can train
a machine learning model, some sort of, you know, neural network, usually
to come up with some weights, et cetera that then once it's trained,
you can give something
some new, unseen task
that it can predict the output for. And to do that, you need some inputs and you need
some outputs.
So in the context of computational fluid dynamics,
the inputs could be lots of cars or planes or wind turbines.
It could be their geometries. It could be their volume measures.
It could be a a variety of things, but essentially the inputs are usually
the simulations of many
cars or planes,
or it could be
more the same plane or the same car.
But lots of different boundary conditions,
so different wind speeds different your angles
and the outputs
could be
their lifts and drags,
or it could be their flow fields of the lost
and the pressure and the nodal points on the mesh.
And the model is essentially learning that
link between those out inputs and outputs
such that now because it's learned that mapping.
I can give it an input, let's say a new car or plane
and it can go and predict me
that output.
But the real reason I guess that it's so
appealing
is because
that actual prediction step
that inference step
is essentially nearly real time
seconds, typically less than a minute.
And if you just focus on that pure
imprint, step that pure prediction step
and you say it's, let's say, worst case, let's say a minute
a minute
on what's often,
uh, you know, a single GP, U or even AC PU at this inference step
compared to
I don't know,
um, 48 hours
on
1,000 CPU cores
48 hours to a minute
is a dramatic change, and that's why you're seeing many companies many papers
claim
10,000 times faster and strictly That is true. It's 10,000 times faster.
I think if you do the maths
now, people will say rightly so. Well, what about the time to train the model?
Well, the time to train the model
depending on what What methods you're using. And if you look in the literature
is probably still in the in the hours, maybe maximum a day.
So the training cost of time is is actually,
um, for these sort of, um,
methods typically not actually
that long
compared to the cost of a CFD. Um, simulation.
Now I'm talking at a very high level here. I appreciate it.
I'm just trying to set the scene. Really?
There's nuances and there's different approaches,
and that's what we're gonna explore over the next few episodes.
But in general,
the cost of training and the cost of inference
is actually
relatively cheap.
The big one, of course, is you have to have the training data,
and this is the interesting similarities and
differences between machine learning for scientific problems
and machine learning for, um,
I'm not sure how you would phrase it, but for large language models,
for the stuff that what you use in these, uh, chat G,
BT or Amazon Titan or Bard or or or Llama model
in those scenarios
the training data
is widely available because it it's and maybe it's getting harder now.
But previously it was simply
scraping off the Internet lots and lots of of texts and documents, et cetera.
Now many of these companies have signed deals
with, um, magazines or newspapers or various other entities to get the data.
But it's I would say, it's largely available
and, um, not huge in size. So if you look at these models, the actual data itself is,
you know, gigabytes or terabytes. It's not in the petabytes
and the real cost of training these large language
models that many of you are starting to use
it is not the data collection per se, although there is work to do that, you know,
labelling and preprocessing,
but more the actual training time. So you know you might need
4000 or 10,000 GPUs running for weeks, and this is what's driven this huge boom in AI,
uh, chips, because the training time is so massive.
If you contrast that with, um,
this is why we jump into so many rabbit holes. So
bear with me
for many people at the moment.
The big difference is that
for scientific problems? Many people are not talking about
foundational models,
and I'll explain what I believe that stands for in a moment,
but more that you are training a model
each time, essentially,
so
the training time is for your specific 50 cars or 100 cars, or or your specific, um,
Earth model or your specific drug discovery.
And so the training time is actually not that much and not that expensive.
What is the real challenge is collecting the training data
foundational models.
The whole point of a foundational model is it's meant to be so foundational
that
you should train it once essentially, and then you can just
use it,
with the exception being that maybe you need to fine tune it.
But when you go and use any of these commercially available large language models,
you are only doing a prediction step. You are not training the model.
It has already been trained on so much data that is considered almost foundational.
There is a current debate in the scientific community,
but I think it's fair to say that most of the stuff that's been done
to date
in the scientific side, whether it's weather modelling, or CFD
are not foundational models
because they only work for quite a specific,
um,
use case that it has been trained for.
So it's not able to predict any fluid dynamics or any weather scenario.
It is still within the confines of a particular thing.
One of the debates is.
Could we build foundational models for science?
And that's one of the topics I'll be discussing with some of my guest.
And I'm purposely not saying the names of the, um of the guest to keep it.
I'll I'll, I'll sort of leak that information, Um, once they're actually recorded.
But the but the it's quite exciting,
and I'm really pleased who I've managed to convince to
to have a chat and share their their wisdom.
Um,
so
the all of that was to essentially say, Why is it so interesting?
It's interesting because ultimately
the promise is that you can get a method that, once trained, can run
in quasi real time.
So if you are a car manufacturer, a plane manufacturer wind turbine,
you can
design
and explore thousands of designs in in in minutes.
Now that all sounds too good to be true doesn't it? Well,
the the truth is that, um
at the moment, there is still a, um, active debate
on how accurate are these methods? Uh, and what can they actually do?
So there's been lots of
I would say fundamental work,
and there are various start ups in the space who are claiming they can do more,
but it's it's It's a very active area of research that,
I would say,
is nowhere near as mature as some of these large language models that have
that people are using every day and you can actually see their usefulness.
But there was a huge amount of promise.
And so what I want to do over the next few episodes is tease in
where these industry experts think we're at
and and where we could go to.
One of the things that you're probably
thinking,
and I just want to briefly explain and mention
again as a context to these upcoming ones,
is
physics.
When you're training these large language models,
one of the interesting thing is that
when it when you ask it a question, you ask it to write a sentence.
You have not told it explicitly. What are the laws of the English language
I If we're talking about English now, you haven't told it these. These are the AL.
This is specifically the alphabet. These are the rules.
These are the grammar rules.
Instead, it's actually learned it essentially from the data.
When it comes to,
let's say, fluid dynamics.
There is one argument
that,
and this is typically called sort of data driven approaches that
if you give it enough data,
it inherently learns
the laws of physics through the data that it ingests,
similar to how a larger language model is able to
essentially learn the language without explicitly knowing the rules.
And you could argue this is a little bit how a child learns
at
the beginning.
They're speaking the language through sort of
just observation through trial and error,
without explicitly knowing the rules.
Whereas an adult, maybe then you actually have to learn the rules.
And that's a whole other topic, how the brain
works.
And anyone who learns a foreign language knows it's much harder when you're older
to do it when you're, um, when you're younger.
But um,
when it comes to through dynamics,
there is the opposite viewpoint,
which is that?
No, we must include somehow
these physical laws
in the machine learning model in the loss function
it some mechanism
to force it to abide by these foundational physical laws,
the conservation of mass conservation of energy
that we know are real and and help us.
And that is typically what are called
more physics driven or physics informed approaches.
And it's very interesting debate,
I would say still a very ongoing debate in the literature on which one of these
is essentially the winner.
Um, which is the most correct? Or
is it somehow something in the middle where, um, it's a
little bit of data, a little bit of physics?
This, um, in my mind is very interesting,
and it's still not clear,
uh,
whether it will be one of these sort of models that have
been coming out Or is it going to be something completely different?
So
I hope that I've maybe just framed a little bit of what's coming.
What really I want to tease out in the next few months is to hear from these people,
first of all,
where they see the current state of the art
where
things are going and their optimism to what a future will look like in 5 to 10 years.
Will we ever be able to have these foundational models of science
where we could essentially almost ask it in a prompt like fashion?
Solve these equations and it can go off and do it
just as I can tell it. Now write me a script that does this.
Is it theoretically possible that if it could learn it,
that we could actually be solving some of these fantastic problems just in
a A you know, a few, um, types of a keyboard. It's for me. It's super fascinating one.
And I know it divides many people.
Some people see machine learning as just a huge hype that is marketing.
Um I.
I felt that way a little bit at the beginning.
Now I'm convinced, actually that it there are huge potential changes,
Um,
and something that everybody should be far more aware of
because I think it has a potentially transformative effect,
particularly in the engineering,
um, industry that, um just as
computers and simulation transform the sector from the previous
days of sort of trial and error, physically making things
that the the question is,
how much can machine learning bring out a new revolution in those industries?
So, yeah,
um,
that's this episode. We're gonna keep it sweet. Gonna keep it short.
And, um, please watch out, please subscribe, please.
Like, look out at the next few interesting, uh, episodes I think you're gonna like.
I think you're gonna learn a lot from
And, um, I. I hope you'll join me for those. So thanks very much for listening to this
and, uh, yeah, hopefully, uh, you'll join us for the next few ones too.
That